aloha reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John old Humphrey we are going to do a
unique challenge from gene Jeter this is
a request from him try not to get hungry
Popeyes Chicken sandwich taste test one
image is gonna pop up and I'm gonna go
I'm hungry I lost end of video
I am you guys go over to gene Jeter's
channel he's got a bunch of videos
sketches short films weird try not to
challenges some were like the most
unique trying to laugh challenges you'll
have ever seen trying to be fascinated
was a gray one videos of models a whole
bunch of stuff guys seriously good stuff
go check it out
cat never done it trying to get hungry I
think this might be the first one's ever
existed I don't know I didn't do
research if you had the popeyes chicken
sandwiches everyone's raving about no I
just hear people are goring each other
to get them just hear that every Popeyes
has had some kind of violent incident
wherever it was like as much i've looked
next to so many Popeyes I don't think
I've ever been a pop I don't think I
have but I go to KFC that's right I've
been to a KFC in Kentucky I get stripe
or somebody in line kills okay it looks
good don't like pickles and not willing
to jail for it or anything it's good
crispy okay bye
so I went to Popeyes and gosh yeah fried
chicken sandwich so we're gonna give it
a little taste test and see if it's
truly worth all the hype that everyone
has been saying looks like your basic
fried chicken sandwich you've got crispy
fried chicken and some sauce and it
looks like some pickles so let's give it
a taste test on my pickles
don't like pickles at all mmm that's
pretty good yeah the chicken is really
crispy the sauce is really good too with
the chicken it's not too spicy
Tsuru and the breads really soft and I
love pickles so special so that goes
really well with the fried chicken I
think I would definitely recommend the
Popeyes Chicken
I hate pickles see what the height is
okay I hope review Brian's up in this
somewhere or whatever is anything
my review would be me heating it and
then really hittin the treadmill whilst
running chicken sandwich no one's been
through the man that thing's huge
look at the size of that thing let me
tell you something get lockjaw when you
go down on this really big it's not like
butterfly cut in half and the bun is
really tasty
it's almost like one of them to play two
roles which is really good it's not too
much crispy on it it's just the right
amount of crispy it's not overdone and I
ordered it without sauces for a reason I
wanted to taste the chicken and he's
really good and it's like literally the
whole chicken breast yeah it's got a
million views
sandwich I've said have anything good
about I'll tell you what greater reveal
of this not with anybody this is really
good
I mean got really nice crispy stuff here
this is serious this is really good
sandwich look at that I'm selling me
sick of that chicken
where's review bra he must have dried
the sandwich surprisingly um I think
okay with that I was like yeah it looks
looks good I'm not craving at them I'm
curious where I can start to smell fried
chicken you know you have like that
sense memory when you see food that
looks delicious you can almost smell or
taste usually it's the taste for me
around like me if I've had it before if
it was like a number two and McDonald's
which are two cheeseburgers in a fries a
drink I might have been like ooh oh yeah
because I haven't eaten it and because I
haven't been a Popeye's that like I
don't think I've ever been a Popeyes we
gotta go after this shoot and get the
sandwich wait 45 minutes for it and then
do a react review I thought you might
have been a bigger sucker for this
because you he's a much bigger chicken
sandwich fan than I like you loves its
crispy chicken sandwich is like Burger
King and all that with the original
Burger King oblong one is the greatest I
love like that's my treat
yeah yeah I thought you would this would
have been like really hard for you and
also I I really hate pickles if there's
a couple of foods I really don't no
matter how many times people are like
try you have to eat it with it it
constantly there are times where I don't
even know if there's a pickle in
something I'm eating and then I I bite
into it and then I'm like I can just
taste the pickle and I'm like so yeah
and
corn we're the I could eat like
cornbread and I could eat pickle chips
but I don't crave those things that's
about as far as it goes from me yeah
pickles are one of the most off-putting
two things to me other than the last guy
seemed like he just got a pen so funny
about it because it's all about the
chicken and I realized it's like the
guys who complain about like oh you got
chocolate in your latte you want a
milkshake if this is a chicken
equivalent I'm a flavor guy those are
good I like flavor yeah see that was the
things the first one got me closest
because she she gave the best visual on
the sale like I guess the inside I could
see the sauce well I could see what was
going on in there for a moment
I imagined a McChicken because like the
way they may oh those is especially
satisfying I thought about that scene
then now now I'm it was in the video
that it but this discussion it was
making me go yeah chicken sound I made
chicken a while good dollar too you can
get a mix again you can go to Carl's get
a spicy chicken how much does this
sandwich cost - that's what nobody
covered is it worth the price not just
the time if I've watched this a couple
weeks a few weeks ago I might have
really been like craving this recently
I've been doing the 16 and 8 of
intermittent fasting so I've gotten
better at saying no to food and also I
made a commitment for 2022 for at least
50 there's 52 weeks in a year right
typically yeah so that's why I've chosen
52 days out of the year to not have meat
but before is just gonna be a once a
week thing I've done about 10 days so
far without meat because I just feel
better well so I feel like I'm slowly
the ozone yeah well yeah I know is
everyone I've been doing it for like a
whole bunch of reasons but like from the
environmental stuff and then the animal
like a whole bunch of read and then I
just started realizing that I just feel
better the next day when I don't have
meat saying no to meat is another thing
it's not American wait how many days in
them in the month ago the day of uh
filming this is the 16th 17th day bad
boys 3 so most of the days out of
January I haven't
well that's pretty crazy to me yeah out
done this video could have been heavily
tempting but but Janna just to keep it
together well I mean when we lived
together you know I I chicken every day
chicken was the chicken and bacon like
every day I loved me having less
cravings for it has been pretty easy if
I watch this anytime for this month I
probably would have been like give me a
pop I made a decision
maybe maybe on social media you know one
of us will get one and do like a you
know like a live reaction step what are
you late into that that's hot that's
what I'm gonna start doing to build my
Instagram lately trends just do live
reactions to foods and other things late
to the trends actually that's kind of
catchy yeah man just cover trend that's
great cuz then you never have to be
timely you never have to jump on what's
hot you can just go back a few weeks and
find what it's good back there and then
bring it up to the the new and then the
people rediscover it either way Jean
this is this is fun 40 I just yeah I got
really aggressive the thing is like
you're so sincere it is like review of
it yeah I mean I feel like this was a
curated pitch first I expected a lot
more clips and just like a lot more
decadent shot like I thought it was
gonna be very like let's Google the the
sandwich for me as a commercial clip or
something but this was just like three
reviews you know we got like a matte
review is a pretty good review and then
like that glass guy just loved it yeah
like this is a great sandwich for four
reviews oh yes right who's the fourth
one my father the black guy you race
yeah the guy who did nothing the guy who
had no reaction too good I couldn't help
but wonder if that was some kind of
cheeky troll or as like alright I'm
gonna do that food reacting alright I
ate it we're done but now it seems like
people who love Popeyes really love
Popeyes and that's about my fear I'm
pretty good addicted yeah yeah but then
again I never I never really got to the
chick-fil-a craze either room like they
open up a chick-fil-a like two minutes
away from from here we can see the line
out the window I've never been I've
never cared drop by anyway gene thanks
so much for requesting this dude you've
been a great supporter of the channel
the grist for a patreon page as well a
wonderful kind human being keep
photographing hot female and male models
keep making crazy weird ass videos
driving on the connections you make and
you have some really awesome goals in
mind this year and I hope you fulfill as
many of them as you can you're an
independent artist you are well talented
kick asses your buddy
thank you and send us some Popeyes